you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
such a fun episode with one of my
favorite comedians she is incredible she
has a new special it's on max
or HBO I think you call it Max
now the guy the last guy to put this
together I think it's Max now uh anyway
HBO or M it's on but anyway uh it's
called salute me or shoot me she is so
funny the special is incredible I'm so
glad she's here uh she also had a talk
show we talk about quite a bit also on
Max that I love that you should check
out anyway everything Sam J does just
check it out this conversation is so fun
so interesting and so funny and I'm glad
you're here uh only a couple things to
discuss up top one my Netflix special
will be out on October 24th it's called
I am not for everyone and I hope you
like it it's on October 24th I'm also
doing Largo this Saturday in Los Angeles
so if you're going to be in the Los
Angeles area and are listening to this
the day it comes out I will be at Largo
on Saturday tickets at largo-la outcom
the next one after that is November 17th
uh so largo-la docomo incredible guests
on those shows so fun doing new material
messing around and and and some Greatest
Hits as well it's always incredible and
I'm on tour Pete homes.com for all the
dates next coming up is uh I believe
it's Bloomington Indiana then we got
Chicago Washington DC those are all
available on P homes.com even if you saw
me in DC recently
uh not that long ago or Chicago this is
a new hour of material I'm really happy
about this new hour of material and I
hope you can make it that is that this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at Magic mind you guys know I talk about
magic mind constantly I'm always giving
it to the guests because I want the
guests to drink it because it helps us
with creativity and focus it's like
athletes have Gatorade now creative
minds have Creator a what is it it's a
mix of 12 functional ingredients
including matcha neat Tropics that make
you focus and adaptogens that help you
fight off stress you can take it instead
of coffee you can drink it like I do
with your coffee to sort of round out
the edges it doesn't get you wired it
gets you dialed in and even helps smooth
out your coffee experience if you're
taking it with coffee it's incredible I
find it to be mood elevating and helps
me get work done and drops me into that
flow State fight fighting off
procrastination brain fog fatigue and
even some ADD symptoms after 3 to 7 Days
of continuous use it's even easier to
get into that flow State and they have a
money back guarantee and we have a
special offer for weirdos from our
friends at magmind all you have to do is
go to magic
mind.co weird and use my discount code
at checkout weird to get a limited 20%
off your first off offer order excuse me
that's Magic mine. c/ weird and promo
code weird for 20% off secondly we're
brought To Us by our friends at Living
Libations you guys know if you listen to
the show this is a complete living
Libations household what is living
Libations it is a natural powerful
effective highend wonderful alternative
to random chemical nightmares that you
uh use you normally for Hair Skin teeth
Eye Care I was putting creams and
ointments on my body that I thought were
good because they well frankly cuz they
were expensive and I bought them in a
mall and the store was named something
French but these things are filled with
chemicals and levels of toxicity that
were never intended for human
consumption so enter living Libations
not only the most effective Skin Care
Eye Care teeth and baby care products
I've ever found but also the most
natural made exclusively with plants and
oils and extracts that not only will you
be able to recognize you can also easily
pronounce them we use their best skin
ever every night that is what I put on
my face every night vow as well I love
their toothpaste I love their sunblock
love the sun sunblock we're in
California so we use sunblock year round
there's Brody in the background whatever
you need this is a great way to support
the show living Libations has a premium
natural and wonderful product to replace
the random chemical nightmare they sell
at 7-Eleven 15% off go to living lib.com
weird support your body support your
skin support your hair your nails your
teeth whatever and the show living
li.com weird all right everybody enjoy
samj get into it we're
recording I don't want you to feel
tricked I
um the thing I noticed about your
special that I really wanted to
compliment without dive in without
making you uncomfortable cuz I don't
want to make you uncomfortable no no I
have in the past I feel like when you
did the live you made it weird what I
remember about it was I was like I'm
such a fan of your I was telling you and
you were like I remember you go what am
I supposed to do with
that so I was like don't don't do that
but I do this is actually for a point
your stand up this new special slute me
or or shoot me is like it's like it's
like it flows y you know what I mean and
so much my my own standup included I'm
trying to make it flow yeah and this bit
I'm trying to think of the I have a
special coming out the opener ties it's
about New Year and then that kind of
goes into a thing about surveillance and
then that kind of goes into a thing
about techn like it kind of it's It's
bundled but yours is like it reminds me
of Nate baratti do you like Nate y it's
like in that way it's obviously
completely you but he and you you have
something going on that most Comics
don't which is like I could see why
people might think you're just talking
you know what I mean people might be
like she's just a funny she's just a
funny person but I'm going like that
took effort yeah and you're trying would
you talk a little bit are you trying to
disguise the fact that you're doing
standup is that an effort or is it just
like how it came out when you started
doing it is that just your personality I
I think it's just my personality like it
just kind of felt like the best way for
me to do it yeah you know what I mean
like I think you're everybody's trying
to find their style and I I it's
authentic it doesn't seem like you're
going work if I do it like this it
doesn't feel like that yeah but I do
think there is some you know
technicality to it like especially in
getting a flow and having it have some
type of a like damatic ride yeah that
was super like intentional and I had to
like work at that part of it well dude
the I I don't want to give anything away
but the suck a dick stuff at the
beginning first of all I'm obsessed with
how speci I know it's so crazy to say
that two two insane people can I
compliment the suck a dick portion but
the pyic umbrella meaning what it's like
to feel like the man in the relationship
or I love what you said about masculine
feminine energy being a thing and you're
like that's just what's happening uh
you're more of the junior yeah Junior
man that's what you say and then that
section lasts like 30 minutes it's like
it's like a full special of just like
running water like it never feels like I
guess what I'm saying is one of the
enemies of standup is how corn horny and
canned it can feel to be like well yes
and I hate that I've been doing it 20
years and I hate that you have to be
like funny thing about microphones like
there's no natural way to start but you
really you open with that Spanx thing
and then you're off and you stay in that
one offshoot for so long that I was
really like like real
respect like oh like [__] like I think
Comics will notice that but I think
people will notice that that it's like
in the same way with Nate it's like
you're laughing but you're ALS you're
not stressed for the performer yeah and
you're not like being shocked every 5
Seconds like to like like you know what
I mean like being provoked in that but
it's I don't know how like that that
just seems to be where you found
yourself yeah I just was I always was
like when I even started I was like it
has to feel conversational it has to
feel conversational or it's not going to
work for me like I'm just not studious
I'm not good like I'm not I'm not so you
mean you're not like I'm looking at Gary
Gan up there that's a studious dude
can't do that that structure and that
like I just but it's there like when you
go we do it for dogs I'm like that's
that's up there with Seinfeld you know
what I mean that's like an observation
and you tied it in and there's a theme
and you're going somewhere but you're
doing it in this natural way yeah it has
to be a little bit uh Loosey Goosey for
me to like get get my get my bearings in
it you know what I mean once it's I
tried to do it when I first started
doing stand up I tried to be studious
like in every way because I didn't want
to be lazy and I really wanted this and
I was like if I really want this I've
got to take this seriously and this is
going to be the thing I [__] you know
and I tried to like I'm G to sit down
I'm G to write for an hour a day and I'm
gonna like get up and I'm GNA do the
jokes and I was like I this sucks like I
suck I feel like I suck because it dried
up everything that was good about it
dried up everything that was good I was
like I just can't like do it that way
you know so I'm always trying to find
that like very conversational tone I
remember like one of the first times I
got off stage I was like it has to feel
like how I feel when I'm just talking at
a bar to which is your talk show too it
just has to feel like that for it to
work for me and so I'm always just
trying to get the the act the closest to
feeling like we just bumped into each
other on the street and started chatting
right and and even the stuff you're
saying seems like you sat down next to
the most interesting person you could
have sat next to at the bar but meaning
like you're saying some [__] yeah yeah
in the in the good way like you're not
being boring so it's so
unpresentable comedy it's like the kind
of stuff you would say at a sleepover
not that it's like so crazy but like I
get the sense that you're being real
with me which also I mean when you were
starting so you're not like a rasle
Dazzle like with a cane and tap shoes
kind of kid how did you find your way
into comedy I mean it what I'm saying is
it doesn't seem like it was catered to
what you're doing now makes sense but
you were coming up in a time when it was
like show us you got it and like attack
it and and come out and whatever like
how did you find your way did it take a
long time or was it weird getting
started you know so where when I first
when I first tried it when I was like 20
something I was trying to do that like
you know cuz like you said it was like
that yeah and it got up and it was very
bad and I it was very bad and I where
were I was at uh Dick dh's comedy bow I
forgot you were from Boston in Boston oh
my God yeah and it sucks dude and I got
off stage and I was like that's not how
that was supposed to feel I knew that
yeah and this is the first time actually
cuz I've not this is not the first time
I told the story was the first time I
actually could articulate what I mean
when I it wasn't how I supposed to feel
because you put it into words words for
me because it was so canned up I wasn't
me and it felt it just felt like it
didn't fit so then I was like oh maybe
I'm not supposed to do this you know
what I mean and so then there was this
long separation time right I didn't do
it again until I was like 29 wow so when
I when I was like I was 28 about to turn
29 my birthday was in January and I I
got up that December before my birthday
and I just had made this kind of
decision that like I'm going to do this
like me it's the only way this is going
to work it's like I got to do it how it
makes sense in my head even if it
doesn't make sense to people and early
in my career and probably a real Sour
spot for me you're getting some therapy
out of me it's early morning no this is
a weird way to start our day isn't it
it's too early for this um but it's a
sour spot for me like early in my career
because I wasn't like precision and I
wasn't you know
I was I'm not I've never one been of
those like counting the lab per minute
people I've never been one of those you
know it's set up punch I've never I just
kind of went and so I used to get a lot
of criticism from um you know the white
boy guard of Boston that I was just a
riffer I didn't know how to write you
know basically you know like it it kind
of felt like when when uh black people
started bringing like street ball into
like the NBA like the different way to
dri and they was just like oh yeah
that's like Tom Foolery they don't know
the via the globe trouts there actually
is something kind of like weird about
the Globe Trotters like we'll separate
it and put it over here yeah but you
know what I mean like that that kind of
energy of like they don't have the skill
set they're just out here winging it and
it was like in a real like negative way
that really like used to piss me the
[__] off because it was like dude I am I
don't write the way you write but there
is a lot of thinking and writing going
into this and layering and and and
setting it up to get these punch lines
off but I'm not a traditional the
punchline might not come where you think
it's supposed to come right right you
know what I mean so just because that's
the way I play it it it became like
contentious you know what I mean but it
also kind of made me dig in my heels
harder and be like I'm going to do it
this way and it I'm going to do it so
[__] good right you know like just
like the street ball thing now it'll be
like oh that's that's the way we do it
the way we do
it through the legs you mean through the
legs a little around the back yeah now
it's legitimized but there was I think
that's a that's an metaphor it's the
same with music too there's there's like
a time where it can be perceived as I
suppose we could be nice and say
different but like worse like you're not
trying yeah and I think that's what it
came off to them as as I wasn't taking
it seriously and I wasn't trying I was
just getting up and saying whatever and
it was so frustrating cuz I'm like if
you can't see the the the technical work
that's H like what do you mean you know
but it really was just cuz it wasn't
packaged up the way they thought it
should be packaged up do you think it
was caring potentially or do you just
think it was [__] talk no it was [__]
hate I was trying to put a nice spin on
it and cuz I here's where that question
was coming from I remember
when I was starting there was such a
making it reproducible was like where
the money seemed to be like you're going
to do Letterman or something remember
when that was the bar we're going to do
Letterman and Letterman is like what are
you going to open with like you have to
open with like a my opener was you have
a Hil a cab just to stop it from hitting
you that was like like I needed that
like right out the gate out the yeah
something right away yeah and when I
remember it was me and Kumil would watch
somebody and I remember Kumil just going
like you know he doesn't write his bits
down
and it was just like saying like he's
not he doesn't take it seriously like he
does he never does it the same way twice
but K didn't mean it in like uh this
piece of [__] you'd be watching someone
and this was not a black person just for
what it's worth just watching someone
kill and being like how are they going
to do it again now that seems to be more
normal and actually it's actually what
I'm complimenting you on is there's
Parts in your act where you go like you
know old people with their advice to
young people like blah blah blah and and
you just kind of Go Blah Blah Blah Blah
like you don't say it and that's not the
point like here's what I think what it
is is like you realize and tell me if
you agree with this the point isn't the
words the point is it's like an excuse
to hang out with a funny person being
funny does that make sense yeah it's not
like I'm going to manipulate you with
like how many pairs are in two pairs of
pairs well it's actually six you know
and then you're like okay that's one
kind of Comedy yeah and then there's
just hanging out and even just hanging
out makes it sound like lazy or stupid
but there's more natural more flow yeah
that's and exactly and that's what I was
really trying to find I was like well
there's that's that's their way to do it
but that way doesn't fit me and there is
this way to like make this natural flow
and you know people like have said that
about me my whole career like you I've
never really seen you do the same set
twice it's always kind of but for me
that's a necessity like I I get bored
yeah so quick and I feel like the
audience can tell when you're done and
it's like now you're just serving up
[__] and they're just you know it feels
gross it just feels so disingenuine and
nasty and one thing that is very true
about me is I love comedy so much I have
such a respect for it so a lot of my
ways of doing it is to protect that my
love for it to keep me wanting to do it
because once you love with your wife
yeah because like once you turn it into
like a job and now I got to get up and
you know like I'm not studious I don't
like jobs once it things feel like that
for me we'll quickly not be together so
I was just trying to make sure I I kept
it alive for me you know so okay a lot
of things about that first of all you're
talking right to my heart cuz I'm
touring right now and that fifth show on
a weekend and you're kind of like [__]
this goddamn thing again so I know some
Comics that that'll go out of order and
that's one way to keep it fresh uh it
seems to me what what is your approach
you're going to say it differently like
you don't know I go out of order
sometimes I say it differently sometimes
like in this very like kind of
destructive way I just blow the whole
set I just like I'll start in a really
[__] up place that I know they're
going to hate me for I'll turn them
completely against me have it be
contentious and then try to win them
back I just got to do something it's
like it's a little psychotic but it's
like if I don't do this these play these
games I'll just hate this you're touring
for like a you're doing hour you're
touring for like a [__] I toured for
a year and a half yeah yeah you know
right I got to I got to find the fun or
what are we doing but do you have let's
say you do a show and you say the bit
perfectly like I'm thinking about when
you said you you get them against you
you say I don't care if people say the N
word with the hearty or and it's like
you can even feel this crowd that's
probably mixed I was listening to it in
the car so I wasn't watching but it's
like mixed and people are kind of like
different reactions and then you win
them over but you have this part where
you go it's never a white person on the
way up and I'm like okay there's the
music I go that that's the lyrics it's
never a white person on the way up the
first time you say that so you're
writing from stage I'm guessing
do you write down it's never a white
person on the way up do you jot it down
do you listen to the set like how do you
make sure when you were filming that
special without ruining it you also
don't want to forget to say it's never a
white person on the way up that was the
last Branch they could grab like that's
good language once I love it I just love
it you'll have it and I'll have it yeah
like once I landed that language I was
like oh no that's it like right and I
love saying it it makes me chuckle you
know like when when it's when it make
you know it does it does a little thing
for me to say it you know what I mean
it's like that's when I I know I'm
hooping now I'm like oh that's that's
nasty you got to keep that that's nasty
but if you don't do it for a while you
don't have any way to refresh it do you
listen to it or look at it you know I
will I will write stuff jot stuff here
and there but that usually becomes a
jumbled mess eventually it's just like
what the [__] is this
yeah just say it's never a white person
on the way out it's like what is this
note is this what the [__] am I talking
about so um I will say because I was I
was more concerned with the Precision
this special like I think the first
special I was just like oh my God I get
to do a special and I was kind of just
like I hope I'm funny you know but this
one I was like no there's some things I
want to achieve I want some callbacks in
there I want you know I want that I want
that theme in there I want that line you
can kind of pull through the whole thing
yeah certain stuff like that so once I
was into like the four Monon period of
like it's like about four months left my
homie um his name is Radio he was like
yo um I'm down to like tour with you and
just like help you you know round this
thing on out and what he would do that
was great was like he's great at
listening he really like likes comedy
but he'll like he pays attention and
he'll say yeah you did it this way or
you did that way y y and that was super
helpful that's what Matt McCarthy my
opener I feel weird calling him my
opener We Tour together he does the show
and he watches and he gives me little
notes my wife used to do it and she's
with the baby just somebody to do that
and if you can pour it in my ear right
before I go on like hey you said it this
way like I had a joke on the special I
go you ever take the lid off a pint of
ice cream no see I said it wrong you
ever take the top off a pint of ice
cream and just throw the lid away yeah
and one time I said it exactly like that
it was top then lid and he told me and
that's the way we did in the special but
it was him it's like this Secret World
of like allies that doesn't get talked
about enough cuz we're all like I write
my own [__] yeah sure but sometimes it
helps to have absolutely and it's like
and I don't think that takes away from
anything you're doing you know what I
mean it's like dude I'm up here I'm
talking for an hour every night I I I'm
I'm growing to hate myself you know I'm
I'm like you should you should shut the
[__] up you know like so sometimes you
just need somebody to be like hey man
cuz sometimes you're like Auto yeah you
get off and you're like I don't even
know what the [__] happened do you ever
get vulnerability hangovers sometimes I
get off stage and I'm like why did I
tell them all that cuz you're talking
really honestly about did you get
married yet not so you're fi so you're
talking really honestly and I'm loving
it and I have all the stuff that I'm
doing about my parents and it's really
like real it's like making fun of them
and having fun and sometimes I get back
to the hotel and I'm like why did I why
did I do that you get that way too
absolutely cuz you're tired you know and
You're vulnerable and you're falling
asleep and you're like why did I make
fun of my my fiance why I tell them that
personal thing or whatever especially
when they come up to you afterwards and
like they want to sometimes you forget
you said it yeah and then like yeah man
I [__] it on myself before too and
you're like what and then you're like oh
yeah I did I did overshare in that
moment that happens to me all the time
it makes sense while it's happening and
that's kind of the job would you agree I
I feel like we're getting paid to deal
with those compc feelings absolutely I
think that's the job and I think that
like not enough Comics acknowledge that
that's the job it's like they're you're
getting paid because you're willing to
go there you're getting paid because
you're willing to be uncomfortable
you're getting paid because you're
willing to push people's ideas you're
getting paid because you're willing to
explore other ways to think about things
you know what I I mean like other than
that what the [__] do we need to be like
listening to you for right right and
you're and you're risking something
that's what I like got to what I like
about your comedy and comedy in general
is when it's going like look I think
there's love under everything you say
about your fiance but I love that you're
like and I'm out here managing stuff and
she's interrupting my man managing it
with her nothing nothing and I'm like
that is I had bit Envy I was like that's
so funny to be like how much do you
think I spent on this hat is you're like
that is ready I know you already filmed
it but I'm like that's ready to go I'm
like that was ready to go but like what
I'm saying is the job is the risk that
they might be upset by it and maybe you
would have to deal with it you kind of
have to play this weird card like we
Carney people or something go like
that's that's what's happening
and what I like we're giving language to
is that sometimes it feels weird to us
yeah abely it's not just that we have to
deal with maybe my dad will think it's
weird that I'm making fun of him for you
deal with real repercussions and your
own yeah man and like and it's like it's
fact like there's definitely like you
know me and my fiance we went through
like a rough patch and I like I cheated
and we were just in a funky ass space
and like I'm on stage like talking about
cheating in this way that's honest to me
and like you know we're we're getting
home and I'm in a living hell you know
I'm in hell wa she's at the show yeah
sometimes list to you talking about and
then she like so that's just your real
opinion so you actually don't give a
[__] and I'm like man we'll talk about
this cuz it's it's part of you right
yeah like I don't know what you said
about cheating but I'm assuming it's
funny to to sympathize with yourself
actually yeah you know 100% and
understand why you did it mostly I was
just saying like she takes it so
personal and she wants me to give her
this big reason why I did it and she
wants this really like deep emotional
reason but
honestly I just wanted to [__] some new
[__] and I didn't think past that and
that's the bad thing you know what I
mean it's like I just didn't consider
anything but what I wanted but it's not
deep like it's not
right so funny I swear that thought has
crossed my mind where it's not the
cheating it's like I had a friend that
that did that and it was not that what
he did it's almost that he didn't
understand what it meant to her yes and
that's that really that was a to I would
say we were in therapy for like a year
and a half that's what I ended up
understanding I was like what I learned
in therapy was like oh this is bad
because it hurts her feelings it it took
like you know I mean because I was at a
place where I'm like girl I didn't do
this cuz I love this girl I don't care
about this girl but all that stuff was
making me sound worse that's what I was
going to say that's the premise is it
worse that you're like I don't care I
also you know I had a I never uh wrote
it down but I had a premise where it was
like you say it didn't mean anything to
me again the same friend who cheated on
his wife and he's like it didn't mean
anything I was like yes it did it was
the I'm not talking to you I was like it
was the greatest moment of your [__]
life like you were miserable you were
depressed and you found someone that
loved you and was paying attention to
you and you [__] loved them in that
way and now you're like and I don't give
a [__] well that's true
now moment giving you what you whatever
you was wasn't getting or whatever ego
thing you needed
or being neglected like you're think
about the trash it's like and that's why
he gambles with the mortgage exactly
it's like we don't even know why we're
doing what we're doing and the cheating
might be like more complicated than we
know right but recognize it's funny I
love that you had to go to therapy cuz
that is relatable just to go like oh it
meant something to her yeah like I need
to care because it it matters to her so
much well that's your bit about guess
how much I spent on this hat yeah the
brain says who [__] cares the heart
says she's just what I like to say is
subtitles on she's saying are you
thinking about me do you care about my
life that's all it is yeah and that's
like that is the growing up into like my
transitioning from a junior man to a man
I think a part of that is learning like
yeah that's the [__] job you know
what I mean and like at the end of the
day like I'm at this place I'm like y I
would never cheat again and I can say
that solidly and holy know that because
I don't want to hurt her feelings it's
not because I think cheating is bad it's
not because I feel honestly I don't feel
any of that stuff but I just don't want
to hurt her feelings it's it's not worth
hurting her because she actually gets
hurt you know dude I'm so there with you
I tried to do this BD where I was like
I'm just not a sex person meaning like I
don't want to balance my sex checkbook
and have like nine different things
going and who do I which one of these
people are we saying I love you like who
likes butt stuff you know like I don't
want to balance all that effort so I
talk about that on say I go I'll never
cheat on Val but it's not even because I
love her and my my take is cuz I'm just
done meeting new people I'm bored
meeting new people yeah it's that too
it's definitely that too but I really
yeah for sure but I really just had to
like grow up and go like do you want to
be the type of person that hurts your
girl's feelings right right and is it
yeah and I was like no that's not the
type of person I want to be do you want
to be a liar it requires some I had to
be honest with myself like you're being
deceptive like these are just not
qualities you want to have but when it
was being brought to me on the base
argument of like how could you [__]
somebody else and love me it was like
easy that's that's not that's not a hard
thing to do right right that's actually
not the issue the issue is that you
don't like that I had sex with somebody
else cuz I could do that all the time
and who care we're going to live in that
part of the argument right we're going
to live in that part of the argument
what are we doing you know yeah but I
love that you got to a place where you
could understand cuz you talk about
empathy and you're special too and
that's a really hard thing to do I
actually found that kind of emotional
because I was like that's so many of our
parents it would have been nice if
somebody just took the time to empathize
I feel like that's a modern we're still
not doing great but we're trying more to
empathize and maybe we have more time to
empathize I don't know that's true too
my dad was riding a bike with a huge
front wheel or what old time try not to
give them too hard of the time there was
like the Dust Bowl like they were just
they were dealing with a lot of [__]
black and white everyone wore hats like
they were delivering newspapers and
there were a lot of fist fights um yeah
so we're we're dealing with the stress
what you said something in the special
and and I just had it and I'm forgetting
it and it doesn't really matter great
how do you feel today I feel good man
I'm
like it feels good to be done with it in
a lot of ways just like it is what it is
now and drop it off yeah and drop it off
and I'm already like
doing new jokes and that's always fun
like I'm doing I'm freef falling again
I'm not I'm not doing it with any like
real reason I'm just doing it because
it's fun and yeah there's no structure
to it and I'm not going in like I got to
work out this piece tonight you know I'm
just like H I got some thoughts about
Joe Biden and that's what I'm going to
do so that's been super fun just to get
back to just the silly billin of it all
this is the conversation I need to be
having I'm going on the road this
weekend and it's just so I know maybe
this isn't that relatable but even with
a dream job it can it can get stale yes
even with a dream relationship it can
get still it's the same kind of thing
you have to like work at it and and what
you're reminding me is like like I got
to disrupt it you got to disrupt
absolutely that was your talk show too
was very disruptive I really love your
talk show thank you and I was watching
it always cracks me up because even
before I met you that white people like
it no that white people like you white
people like you I have this expectation
of the white person in my head that
likes it and it is not PE home by any
stretch so even when I first met you and
you were like yeah I like that and you
like actually knew it and watched it I
was like what the [__] I do sometimes
feel bad for the cutting to the white
people sometimes you're having a
conversation and I can I know what the
white people are feeling as a white
person I'm like they don't know what to
say they don't know what they can agree
with and they're just kind of like but
that's very entertaining to me but the
cut to them can be very funny it can be
very very funny is that are you doing a
new season of that or no man the people
didn't the people didn't get it oh
really yeah that's surprising to me yeah
I mean I think when I say the people you
know like Nina and Aaron who I work with
a lot HBO they got it yeah I think when
the new people came in they had a
different agenda and they were like we
don't really see I also but I knew I was
doing something very Niche yeah I always
knew that every the two seasons I got I
really feel like I got away with
something I was like oh they going to
let me do this again okay so I I wasn't
it wasn't devastating by any stretch of
imagination I just it was like that was
cool I got to do that that long right
and it was an achievement yeah for sure
and you did pull something off I I'll
also add to that just to depersonalize
it a little bit a lot of times when
regimes change or people change they
just want to do something new it doesn't
matter if they like it or not they just
like [__] I don't want to keep doing
what someone else was yeah and anytime
I'm I'm I'm very realistic about the
things I make and I'm like first of all
this is a business I'm asking someone
for their money you know like that's the
reality of it that's what getting a show
it's like give me money to do my idea
and I can totally understand that there
was some white man executive who you
know saw a bunch of girls [__] fruit
and me yelling with a big strap on and
was like I don't quite understand
this and I don't know where this lives
that's fine you know what I mean like
that's fine dude you know it would have
been weird if you did get it but that's
what was fun about it was it felt like a
party I wouldn't get to go to and I
don't even mean that as a white person I
just mean as a lame married dead I'm
watching like something that feels
distinctly New York and like fun and
social and and real but it it was really
yeah that's what I was going for yeah so
I mean I feel like I got to do it and I
got to and you know what people like
it's weirdly culty like people come up
to me all the time they're like I
[__] love Pa are coming back and I'm
like no they're like what you know
like oh my God somebody was kidna this
is a fale alert leave me
alone yeah have you noticed that
because everyone's posting clips of
social on social of crowd work that
Crowds Are talking to you more yes and I
[__] hate it I [__] hate it too
and I want the people to stop doing I
want us all you know who has the power
to stop it's us yeah I mean theow [__]
[__] stop it I get it man you're
posting the worst part of your show I
get that you don't want to burn material
like maybe it's just a picture of your
breakfast I don't know but like yeah is
the Crowds Are rowdier they're talking
and they think they matter it's like I I
think truly they do it's like they
matter to the show it's like we better
do some [__] or we won't have anything
to post you can't embolden them like
that you have to you have to let them
know that they're insignificant at the
same time that's you're the most
important thing it's a sick little game
but you have to let them know like yeah
you you don't run this it doesn't work
and I don't need you to do this right I
think they think they're helping oh they
Absol already problem and they
absolutely think they're part of it now
and they're like I'm giving you a leg up
that's right thank poor guy or lady
doesn't have anything to post I'll give
him something that'll go viral I'll give
him a viral moment get the [__] and now
there's cameras on them the cameras
don't go that way cameras go this way
don't talk to me that's the whole point
don't me it's for everyone's good it's
for everyone's good if
[__] I'm trying Mario Bali is cooking
you a meal you don't come up and start
dicing stuff like let him cook yeah I
don't like it I wish the people would
stop me too it just happened I went out
on stage and I made sometimes if I see
an empty chair I'll in the front I'll
gesture to it everybody does it I'll be
like empty chair and someone just yells
out it's fur and the name of the person
they came with who I went to to college
with and I was like what are you doing
like we're talking in the first 10
seconds of my show which by the way if
you have a guest their friend is going
to [__] up the show have you noticed
that phenomenon if you invite somebody
they're going to bring someone that's
going to yell some going to do dumb [__]
CU it's free yeah have you also noticed
that if you have guests at the show and
they come back they won't say anything
about the show
yeah isn't that crazy yeah I'm just so
happy that you know what I'm talking
about you'll put 11 people on the L they
all come back no one says great show no
sometimes might because Matt McCarthy
knows this we'll be like and what a
great show like we'll we'll start saying
no they won't say anything they just
start talking about other [__] right
green room but it's gray all sometimes
like they'll come back and they'll talk
to you about like the opener yeah you're
like I'm not trying to be like a
narcissist here but but dude it's this
is what we were talking about earlier is
they think we're like high on our own
Supply after the show when really we're
drained
tired and you had people that you knew
which I don't want and you could use
just a little like that was great that
was great and and I will say this you're
high but it's like it's like not a good
one it's complicated yeah it's not a
good one yeah it's like mushrooms you
talked about mushrooms in your special
which I love and you know when you're on
mushrooms and you're like this like
you're looking at reality you're like
this is all good I don't know about this
like literally an area like don't I it's
not it's not bad yeah but I'm not gonna
look over there for a little while y yep
because it's got like kind of like a
hairy dark something doing something and
I think it wants me I think it wants me
to go like and get pulled into it yeah
but I'm not going to let myself yeah
yeah how often are you doing that
mushrooms you know I don't I don't know
whenever I feel like it you know it's
not not like an everyday thing but I'm
not like oh I can only do it once a
month I'm just like whenever I'm in the
mood oh really yeah so you're
I get sometimes I somebody gave me some
mushrooms recently and just the smell of
them and I get kind of like like it
reminds you of what it can do and you
get kind of like tense but you you're
not afraid of them no I'm not afraid of
uh my brain yeah so and I'm I don't know
no never had a bad trip of course I have
of course I have you pull yourself out
of it or do you just I go to bed baby
you go to bed absolutely really yeah if
it starts going left I'm I turn off all
the lights I cut down all the the
sensories yeah I like black out no TV no
music go to sleep and you can fall
asleep even though something's like yeah
hello Sam you're just like I'm just like
no I feel I believe that you can no I'm
going to bed but when you when you take
them how much are you taking do you me
sometimes I micro do sometimes you know
I'll take like if I want to like it
depends on what I'm doing cuz like you
know like now that everybody's like into
it and there's like you can micros you
can do this you can do that so sometimes
I'm like I'm on like like a city amount
of shrooms and I'm just like in the city
and I'm chilling and it's like chill
sometimes I'm like oh I want to like
trip that's another thing you know what
I mean so and that's more for nature you
think yeah more for nature if I'm like
in my room and I know I'm like just
going to be listening to some cool music
I just want to like let my thoughts be
expansive and do whatever you know what
I mean the bit I don't want to ruin it
but the bit about seeing white people
dancing while I'm musroom thank you and
then you go but she's on mushrooms and
she goes no they're so free yeah yeah
they're not even Bound by the beat and I
was like that is the most mushrooming
and it's so simple but like for real why
are you being so hard on yourself that
you have to like like music and a body
has to be a certain and my whole life
I've been this hard on myself you know
right yeah you want to like fit in and
mushrooms is like fit in to what we're
in outer space like we're in outer space
and nothing is real be off beat Sam who
cares that is is so funny is there a a
trip that that comes to mind that was
like very profound for you or changed
your
life you don't know I I feel like it was
it wasn't and I've never and this might
be because I've never like I'm gonna go
to the woods or Joshua tree and I'm
gonna [__] trip I've never done that
you know what I mean so that's probably
not why but I feel like every
time it's made
me feel small that's why I explain
musroom like it makes me feel
insignificant in this way that is
necessary like it makes it that's what
it does for me every time it just makes
it just shrinks me and I'm like ah guess
what you don't [__] matter like there
this whole world all this stuff yeah in
this good way of like you don't matter
so like get out your own way and get
your head out your ass because
like people are don't give a [__] about
you that much you know right I like but
there's a good way and a bad way yeah no
no not in a bad way not in like so why
am I alive way it's more in a like so
why am I so hung up on [__] way right
you know exactly I just heard uh Ira
Glass on This American Life was like
name five people from the 15th century
and I was like oh wow that's a good one
like you can't no one can maybe a
historian can do it but like and all of
those people thought all of their stuff
was so important that's what I mean yeah
you know what sometimes I do on YouTube
they have these color corrected like
someone will just put a camera and you
know it was like the size of a suitcase
on a corner in LA in like
1918 and they just let it roll so it was
black and white and it was all sped up
and Goofy but they fix it and they slow
it down and they color it and I'm like
kind of like that a war movie that uh
what you call it D oh yeah yeah uh the
Peter was it Peter Jackson I know what
you're talking about that movie is
awesome that one I need to see that oh
it's so good really I believe it it's
really really good but in the set you
watch and you go like each one of these
people is like late for work or like a
little bit lonely that day and you kind
like so what yeah it's all passing mm
it's all going away that's what shs kind
of does so then that allows me to just
like live more in my own truth and like
go for it and because it's like yeah man
these all just moments you know yeah
somebody it's team of children says like
you're the sky and everything coming
through is like a bird or a cloud and
it's all you know what I mean but there
is something have you ever had that
experience on mushrooms where you're
like what you are is something other
than Sam like you're like yeah and
that's calming too yeah see sometimes I
think it's like when I talk this way
with people that you are like awareness
or you're like knowing you're the thing
that like knows you're the quality of
knowing it's so hard to talk about and
everything else is just kind of coming
and going that's a fun belief I suppose
you could turn that into a religion but
why I'm always talking about that is
because when you rest in that place
there's nothing to worry about yes
that's why and that's why I'm asking you
and that's why I'm glad you had that
experience when I was on mushrooms I was
like this idea that were like separate
that were localized like I'm stuck in
this and the tree is over there and
you're over there it's so [__] it's
paranoia it's like insanity and you're
like I I'm sustained by my my heart and
my brain exactly because it's all like
going to it's all working together and
that's what I mean by you're small like
you're just a cog in the machine you
know like it's all yeah you're a part of
a thing you belong yes that's what the
mushroom will say to you like you're not
a visitor here you're a product of yes
right Alan watt says you don't come into
the world like you weren't born into the
world you came out of the world yeah
it's like you were like an apple on a
tree or something ex it's exactly that
right and it's natural and that's a
really powerful that's I think we're all
looking for the feeling of like am I
okay am I okay here which again is
what's so beautiful about comedy in
general is when you're up on stage and
you're talking about peeing on yourself
first thing like that's what we should
be doing you know what I mean not
talking about winning and dominating and
being rich and talk about your stress
talk about your fear yeah because
everybody's having it and we're all
we're all experiencing this thing and
it's [__] weird it's so [__] weird
do you remember we were on a zoom
together and I think you were Stone
we're like in love it's so weird I never
thought this would
be oh you and
I but every time we get together I'm
like I love this too I love you too this
is great well this is that's what I was
going to say there was this moment where
it was just you and me and we were on a
zoom it was during the pandemic and I
started going off on the we were
watching a lot of Great British Bake Off
and I started going off on this thing
about how baking is
feminine and I was like cuz it comes out
of ovens that's like a vagina it's like
a cave it's all eggs and milk you know
what I mean and everyone was like turned
on me and then you were like I get
it like and then you said I it might be
because I'm stoned but I completely
understand what this person like
everything is so much weirder than we
give it credit for I'm like abolutely
even the fact that you're aware of your
experience is the thing that no one is
talking about like you're here yeah and
like and it's like weird and like nobody
even knows why right and we instead we
just go around and play put balls and
hoops and yeah and like make up the wise
but we really don't know why which is
like then the only why is like as corny
as it sounds cuz it's this all comes
from like hippie culture right in drug
culture but it's very true like the only
why is like to love each other man you
know it's like we be good at one another
man like cherish the experiences of the
moments you're having with one another
because like other than that we have no
explanation for this [__] I think like
love love is the only thing that's real
or love is the only that matters I uh
rert Spyro who I mention all the time he
says it's like this is God's dream and
it's our job to just make it as nice of
a dream for ourselves as possible
like a weird [__] dream why are you
doing and the only thing that is lasting
right is considering like the world
doesn't just like obliterate itself all
at one time the only thing that is
lasting is who you were in the moments
yeah how you treated people how you made
people feel that's what people remember
they they they they like you die people
can't come sometimes even remember your
[__] face but they can remember how
you made them feel yes that's it I think
about this all the time cuz I have a
daughter now and I'm just like in
interstellar they're like it's the
parents job you're just ghosts of their
future like you're their memories that's
my job my only job that's some trippy
[__] right there I'm just here to be a
good memory absolutely so my daughter
will be like I deserve love I deserve a
good person in my life my mom died when
I was 16 years
old but I always say like what she
implanted in Me by raising me and and
leaving those like act ual memories and
the feeling of being loved the feeling
of being valued teaching me how to Value
myself teaching me how to be good to
people when I was being a bully telling
me that wasn't you know correcting that
behavior all of that stuff that's what's
left you know what I mean I don't
necessarily always I can sometimes I
can't even make out her face cuz at this
point I've been alive without a parent
longer than I've been alive with a
parent right so I don't always remember
but you get the faces in the point yeah
but I remember how I'm supposed to be
and I remember how I was loved and I you
know that's what I remember yeah it's so
it's it's beautiful there was a time
when you used comedy for evil you were a
bully there was I I had some years yeah
you know in school yeah but I wasn't I I
will always say there was there was a
time when I was like I feel like every
girl goes to this like she's you're
turning that mean girl corner and I was
like turning it and my mother was like
no you're not going to be one of those
like that's not how we treat people
that's not what we do you know what I
mean and kind of was very like big on
correcting that which I I think was
important cuz I would have turned into
an [__] I do think I was I've always
been a bully but I've always been a
righteous bully I I would say like I've
always I've never like bullied someone
like oh you don't have as much money as
me you you're poor you're but it was
just kind of like man don't be like
don't be corny don't be lame like right
right you know what I mean like right
that kind of [__] like right not just
like pushing a small kid no yeah that's
that's like a 80s bully you were just
speaking your mind and and probably
being funny and being like you know like
if I saw something in
somebody that and I felt like they
weren't like going for it I was kind of
that kind of bully like oh so yeah so
you're just going to be a punk and not
do this you know what I mean like you
want to do it like Fight Club you
remember Fight Club yeah is willling
where they take Raymond out and they go
if you're not on your way to being a vet
in one year yeah I'm that's the type of
you're Tyler
Derber that makes perfect sense yeah so
she died when you when you were 16 when
did you start doing comedy oh not until
you're 20 yeah that's and was that hard
I I'm assuming it was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah took me some a while to find
my way out but again I had the lessons
and that's I always say found yeah and I
always say like you know
my mother still raised me even though
she wasn't around yeah she laid that
good foundation in those lessons and
they were really in there so those were
the things I pulled on to find my way
out 16 years of real mom yeah is better
than 40 Years of half like real mom
going hard yeah yeah yeah I I'm not
trying to be funny when I say you you
got those formative years AB your brain
was forming I was going to say like you
can cram it in that's the thing I wasn't
trying to be F you can like you can sort
of mash it in and it sounds like she did
how did she pass she had lupus and um
just had complications from it that
sucks because lupus is one of those
go-to comedy diseases I didn't even know
you because it sounds like L loopy you
know what I mean it's just kind of a
funny sounding word I've a couple bits
come to mind but like I didn't even know
you could die from that I don't even
know what it is it's an autoimmune
disease where your immune system like
turns on your body essentially oh really
and starts to attack your body like it
just acts like like if it's attacking
your lung it's like all your like white
blood cells are like oh that's a cold
and they go like ape [__] on your actual
like working wow stuff that you need and
there no cure so she no but you can like
there's a lot more like uh maintenance
drugs and like there's a lot more like
knowledge about what it is and that kind
of stuff so yeah but no cure for it and
it was a long like a slow process it was
I would it felt slow but I guess now
that I'm grown maybe it was kind of
quick you know I feel like we found out
I was probably
like N9 or 10 or something like that and
then she passed away when I was 16 how
do you care cuz so you're in high school
how do you care about high school while
your mom oh you don't you don't he's
spiral you know I did it yeah I wasn't
doing well in school I just I was really
like checking out you know cuz me and my
mom were also super close so it was
really tough on me and I was like I was
going into full like checkout mode I was
just like did you have friends I mean
had friends you had friends but how do
you even have a friend when you're going
through something like I mean you need a
friend I've never been like I've learn
learning this in therapy I've never been
able I've always been one of those type
of I'm good yeah people I've never want
like and I think it's mostly because
like I never wanted my friends to treat
me different cuz my friends were also an
escape from what was going on right so
it was like I don't want this this part
of my life in this part of my life when
I'm with my friends I just want to be my
[__] friends I wanted to feel like
chill so I really just wouldn't talk
about it and that's what's good about
kids I mean it's not necessarily the
most helpful thing if that's all you had
but grown-ups were probably like how you
doing like that tone they're going to
crouch down to you and want to get real
and you're like can't I just play
Playstation or whatever you want just
chill or whatever so I really just
wouldn't talk about stuff like that and
is did you get into like escapes were
you doing drugs were you drinking I mean
I started drinking after after after
yeah so I probably like I started
drinking about like 17 and I would say
like in my 20s it was bad for a while
like I was like drinking excessively and
like you feel like it was blackout and
[__] like that tied right to your mom
yeah I was depressed for a long time I
mean we don't know how to mourn we don't
know how to process that that would have
taken like a team dedicated
psychologists to I would say for six
years I was like I didn't see a purpose
you know what I mean for sure I was just
like I don't know why I'm here why any
of this what none of it mattered you
know what I mean I was definitely moving
through life that way for a good chunk
and the drinking was just kind of like
how you got kind of by yeah absolutely
and what was it in 20s you were blacking
out and stuff never got in trouble
though no never got any trouble never
went to jail or anything like that I did
I did a I did a pass out one time and
woke up in a hospital but
honestly I'm not even going to get into
that I feel like I feel like a bunch of
people were overreacting I'll just say
that okay you mean the people that took
you to the hospital yeah it was like
they were doing too much all I needed
was a nap basically I like I
had sure they thought something happen I
had a boyfriend at the time and I had
come back to Boston he was living in
Boston I was living in Atlanta and I was
drinking a bunch in Atlanta like I would
get [__] face with my friends all the
time someone would all like and I'm not
saying it's healthy but we were all
young we were all being wild we were all
now that I look at it running from
different things in our lives you know
what I mean and it didn't seem like a
problem because we were also in a Party
City and everybody was drinking every
night excessively like it wasn't weird
you know what I'm saying I do and if
someone would pass out you know which we
probably should have brought people to
the hospital several times but we
thought we were scientists and we're
like they just get them some water and
just make sure you sit them up so they
don't choke on their own throw up and
we're like we did it you
know that was kind of how we would like
handle [__] like that we' like throw
somebody in the [__] shower you know
what I mean get it together you know but
that wasn't working for you and they
took you no so now I'm like with my
ex-boyfriend he's kind of a [__]
square um love love still love this kid
to but he was a nerd you know you still
friends with your ex yeah like we don't
talk as much as we used to like it's
trailed off in the last two years but
for a while you know we would definitely
really check in with each other um and I
don't know I have a thing for nerds
nerds are just Attract it to me they
just they F I still they just fued to me
I don't know yeah so he was a dork and
we were drinking and I hadn't been
drinking cuz I was home so I wasn't
drinking like I was drinking in Atlanta
but we went out and these kids had like
a bottle of 151 and I was like yeah
we're going to get [__] up tonight and
I like just turned it all the way to 10
and I had him in drinking and I went to
the bathroom and I passed
out um like I went to pee and I like
passed out on the toilet so he said he
came in and I was
like so he like shut up Square he like
freaks out out he calls 911 W and were
you on the toilet like Elvis He sad like
Elvis but I don't know I don't know if I
fell off or what I don't know I'm sure
I'm sure it was alarming I won't take
that
away positive it was alarming there's no
way that it's like dignified it's not
Regal no no I know it was not dignified
you
know and um so and all his friends are
nerds you get what I'm saying yes he
they're not cool friends will be like
she's fine this is how you solve that
they're all like these we got to get her
to the hospital types so they call the
ambulance I don't remember I remember
waking up in the ambulance and thinking
what the [__] is going on and I just
went back to sleep and then I woke up in
the hospital and I was like handcuffed
to the bed like that's what through I
like woke up and I tried to move my arm
and I was like what the [__] what the
[__] and I was like what the [__] where
am I and he was in the room looking very
solemn like he like he had like a full
addict of a girlfriend and he was like
we're in the hospital I'm like boy he's
like you passed out on the toilet and
I'm like why the [__] am I handcuffed
you know like what is that about like
Ethan Hunt like Mission Impossible why
the [__] am my handcuffed and he was
like because you kept SC you were trying
to fight the nurses and then you spit on
a nurse and they had to like restrain
you and I'm like what and he's like yeah
you kept telling them to just get the
[__] off you leave me Al I'm like why
did you bring me to the hospital and he
said cuz you passed out on the toilet
I'm like dude I just needed to sleep you
know right and I'm like so what was I
saying he was like he was just telling
the nurses to get off you and just let
you sleep I was like see like I wasn't
and then I could Justified all my head I
was like I wasn't being hostile to the
nurses there's all this [__] going on
around me I'm [__] blackout it's like
just let me sleep like you guys are like
now poking and potting me and [__]
you're saying why did you bring me to
this place with all these people I can
harass you know what I mean like cuz
you're all you had to do is just put me
in a back
room I would have woke up and been like
all right I feel like I'm on pause was
have you noticed a phenomenon that black
women love dorky white
dudes a little a little sometimes
autistic kind of yeah little Spectrum
I've seen that there's somebody I know
in in my family who's on the Spectrum
white guy obviously and he's he dates
exclusively black women and I'm like
what's going on here yeah we like to
take care is that it was this dude right
no no but he was definitely me yeah yeah
yeah well I guess that's what I was uh I
was I thought I was opening a whole can
of worms and you're like yeah maybe I
don't know I'm not I'm not the Arbiter
of that
topic but you like nerds yeah yeah yeah
you can say you like taking care of like
a a gentler I like people who think
different yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I get
that and then when did you just realize
you were gay you know what I'm saying
like if you're dating this dude and
you're 16
it was like a slow realization for sure
you late right yeah it's late I'm about
24 dicks aren't working out you know and
I'm like I don't know what's
up they're not digs are not working out
it's not working out like I'm trying I'm
trying I'm like can I just sympathize as
someone who also isn't attracted to digs
being like I what a weird situation to
be in like this is what's on the menu
try yeah I was trying hard and I was
like it ain't working I'm trying
different sizes I'm like I don't know
you it wasn't feeling
it just yeah there was just no
connection I just couldn't and then I
was like and I had I had a I had sex
with my ex-boyfriend and we had a
connection but also you know we were
dating since we like we were
15 like it was like young love and like
we went through the death of my mom
together and like all of that so then I
was like maybe that's the thing it's
just like I just have to be in deep love
with somebody but like I'm just like I I
just wasn't into dudes like once I got
into the dating pool you know like my
first boyfriend and then this is the guy
I'm with till I'm like 21 22 years old
so once I got into like the dating pool
I was like I'm just not that into this
this guy carried you through a very
crazy time in your life your mom pass
you're about to start doing comedy you
had your your trouble with alcohol like
a heavy period there so of course you
love this person I like that you didn't
call me an alcoholic you were an
alcoholic I like that you said you had
your troubles you had your
troubles it's like I work for you and of
course Sam had her troubles like but I
don't want to get
fired you had that do you do you think
you're an alcoholic no I think I had
some troubles you had some troubles yeah
you throw it back at me yeah no no no
troubles is different troubles is
different troubles is different troubles
are different yeah just some murky water
for a little bit you know but you were
so bonded let me you tell me where I'm
wrong you felt this person was so there
for you it's the wrong gender but you
love this person there's this Bond
you're like trauma Bond from your mom's
passing difficult time and that must
have really confused things being like I
bet I bet sex was somebody that wasn't
even your thing but you're that close
could be intimate fool you absolutely
that you're like I guess this is I like
penises I guess I I like penises I guess
I'm coming you know I'm not not coming
you right
but it's interesting was it it's not the
anatomy as much with women is it the
connection it's all of it I'm just not
that into it like when I was trying to
find the connection it wasn't there and
then it was like I'm having sex with
these dudes I'm like I'm not [__]
really getting anything out of this and
I'm like I'm going hard don't get me
wrong like I'm going hard you're going
for it I'm going for it a good I'm
trying to decide like am I just like a
freaky [__] I'm having one night stands
I'm like maybe I'm a freaky hoe that's
my [__] like for real you feel pressure
I'm trying to figure it out no I am just
I'm such a [__] weird ass person that
I have to do everything to make a
decision yeah you know what I mean I'm
like I I won't write something off until
I've thoroughly like done it and then I
go okay like no you know but I'm I got
to know person so I'm going hard for it
and it's just not happening I'm just
like I don't I'm not getting anything
out of this and I'm in Atlanta at this
time too and so there's a big black gay
Community there and a big you know black
lesbian Community there and like fine
ass women are hitting on me and I'm like
I don't know why this is happening cuz I
am walking around straight and I'm like
this is weird like am I throwing off
it's like people saw it before yeah but
even when I was young I gave off like
like lesbians would hit on me and [__]
like I've been giving off Dyke energy my
whole life that I wasn't aware I thought
you about to say that and then you were
like you can say that it's your show
yeah I was not aware of so um so it's
like knew before you which has to be
nice to be folded into a community it's
like they came and got you yeah kind of
they picked you up kind of and then I
was like I don't know I'm not I'm again
not I'm a person who's not scared of my
brain and I've I just don't I don't have
fear so it wasn't like a fear it I never
had this like oh my God I never felt
that way I was like I don't know maybe I
should try to eat a [__] and see what
the deal is well and was it like
homecoming oh it was like
whoa wow oh and then like it was like a
like those flashbacks with your whole
life and then I was like oh [__] you're
so
gay oh my God like oh no you've been
like so gay this whole [__] time all
these girls in school that were your
friends you were totally crushing on all
these [__] girls like what the [__]
and it was like it I finally made sense
to myself that awkward cuz I was always
awkward yeah that awkwardness that I've
always felt that I couldn't I didn't
know where to put it yeah it was like
oh you know yeah cool I get it now
that's I mean everybody should be so
lucky honestly that's a little bit how I
feel about comedy sometime you ever do a
set and you're like how are people
getting by without something like that
like you have to find your thing and
sexually you found your thing I mean I
know a lot of straight and gay people
that don't feel that way you know what I
mean like they're not fully expressing
themselves or know themselves well
enough to know what they want so it's
great that you do and the first one was
that a date was that a the first woman
yeah it was like we were we were like
kicking it yeah yeah it wasn't just like
a first date type of thing we had been
kicking it yeah but we weren't like
together and were you together after
yeah because that's how lesbians work I
was going to yeah that's very lesbian
for a while for a while you move in yeah
did not
yeah like sometimes stereotypes happen I
mean it's real it happens yeah sometimes
that's how it
is pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at element lmnt element it's the morning
time as I'm recording this intro I just
drank a big glass of water with my
element in it which makes it so much
more pleasant to drink cuz the flavors
are incredible but it also helps me
actually hydrate my body and not just
flood it with water because healthy
hydration isn't just water it's water
plus electrolytes the problem is a lot
of products that are going to give you
electrolytes are also going to give you
like 20 gr of sugar it's insane so you
need element element is a huge part of
my wellness program and part of my
morning routine that I sincerely look
forward to I start in the morning with
watermelon salt I mix it I'm good to go
what is it it's the optimum ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium that
helps with health performance and energy
because we all know dehydration is bad
news and it takes these elements that we
need in our body to get those headaches
away low energy cramps confusion worse I
use it for that neural connectivity
mainly I also use it after I sauna
obviously I use it after I work out
obviously but just in the morning before
I've even done anything just to
Kickstart My Day get me ready to face it
get everything flowing hydration wise
and feel like everything's in my brain I
absolutely love it it tastes amazing and
if I'm fasting which I often am it's
great to be able to sip something that
is very very I think it's like five
calories which is you know basically
zero calories for me when I'm fasting I
don't really count it that's what I'm
saying I love it and you need to try it
people say that after they run they
drink an element like an orange salt
element and it basically this is what my
friend said he's like it makes me feel
high it it replenishes so much of what
you're sweating out and so much of what
your body needs so support your body
support this show go to drink LM nt.com
weird and use promo code weird and
you'll get a free element sample pack
with any order when you order I love
these sample packs I get them cuz I use
the promo code to get my own element and
it's so fun to be able to try all the
different flavors there's like a
habanero one which I didn't think I
would love there's a mango chili one
there's like spicy ones that I didn't
think I would love and the chocolate
Salt one is incredible hot I often drink
that at night like hot chocolate but
it's like a 5 calorie hot chocolate that
is actually giving your body what it uh
lost during the day so drink element.com
weird for your free sample pack with any
purchase that's drink element.com weird
all right everybody back to the
show but I mean talking about masculine
and feminine what's interesting about
feminine energy that men and women can
have it's like it is so it is so
nurturing it's like we can do this like
I get why two women together might
statistically have more openness to the
potential of this being amazing whereas
men can be like I'm a lumber truck and I
I don't know fire might come tomorrow
and and they're more scared yeah and I
think also
like the nature of masculinity
is so like get out in the world and
Conquer and go and and it's
like we with women it's like I like you
why would I keep going to look for stuff
yeah like I found it yeah I like you I
like this why don't we just do this you
know what I mean right why do I got to
do this and then I know I like this and
then go look for another thing to like
which is so funny because women the
other stereotype is women don't know
where they want to go to dinner you know
what I mean how can it be both how can
it be like on one hand they don't want
to commit to a restaurant but they will
commit to I'm I'm just talking in
stereotypical ter no no I get it um I
think it's because like like men know
where they want to go to eat but they
can't pick a person women don't know
where they want to go to eat but will
pick a person yeah I think it's like the
pass the there's a passiveness that's
kind of ingrained in femininity of like
you don't have to make those kind of
decision well that's in your bet right
that's in your B yeah there's this level
of just like like my girl she she says
it jokingly absolutely she's joking but
I'll be like babe like you need to
[__] tap in like where are we going
or like what what and she's
like babe I have you so I don't have to
think just like tell me she's like I
don't feel like
thinking that is the deal here right
right tell me just let me ride yeah just
let me
ride and I think men I like that Val
this this is look you talk about being
stressy you have to take care of stuff
and I'm with you like maintaining I
actually love that part of the ACT where
you're like man I have to get it and
then they have to maintain it women said
women can build something and burn it
down the same day it's like very funny
men are maintaining it there's all this
stress to it and as I'm listening to it
I'm like it's one of those things that
is stressful and I like it yeah no it's
very satisfying you know what I mean I'm
like but I I even like complaining about
it no yeah absolutely it's all very
satisfying like but that was kind of
like the the the funniness to it to me
was like you know when I was dating men
um on that side of it I see all this
stuff and I'm like what the [__] is
wrong with them why is they making it so
this and so that and then I step into
this M's SP and I'm like the exact same
you know I'm like right like your dad in
the trash yeah like my dad in the trash
and it's like but I also love it I also
it gives me purpose right right I I'm I
wouldn't have it any other way I
wouldn't sometimes I like to just watch
my girl sleep and be like she ain't
thinking about
nothing that's fire like I built I built
I did that did this just not thinking
about nothing yeah and then but then
when I'm stressed the voice of my stress
is like I've said this a million times
but I'm putting it to you I go I know my
job looks fun that's how my stress
sounds I go like it's much harder yeah
like Val was sitting right there she
knows this we talk we're very open
there's a lot of communication in my
marriage I'll be like when I go on the
road that's not a vacation you know what
I mean and I don't even have to say that
to her in Anger we just we just kind of
piece
discuss that so like it's it's a tricky
thing to negotiate if she's going on a
trip but it's not work and it's like and
I have and I'm watching Leela it's like
yeah but I watched Leela when you were
there and I'm like yeah but I was
working yeah and but then I have to
watch it like I do like I I hear my dad
what were we talk so Val wants to be a
director and I I believe in her like for
real I believe in her like she wrote an
incredible script I I can see it I can
see the headphones with the VC on it
those are initials I believe in her and
I'm about it and she's like there's this
director program and she's like it
breaks down by weeks but it's like 40
days or something and I'm like and it's
like 9 to 5 or something in LA and I'm
like getting like a little sweaty and I
hear my dad like I didn't know my dad
was in there as loud as he is but my
dad's voice is like and she's like you
know when you do crashing or something
we were in New York for 4 months and
she's not even trying to tit for she
going we can make this work the same
we've made it work
before and what I'm embarrassed to admit
is that vals had me I've gotten practice
now at going just imagine it was me
because if I was like there's a thing I
it wouldn't even be a discussion it
would just be like I'm do I'm gonna do
I'm doing this and she's doing it but
why and it's because she's not getting
paid to do it but then she's like but
you did stand up for 12 years before you
got paid and I'm like [__] my dad and
I'm not blaming my dad I'm just saying
that hyper toxic masculine voice says if
I make money I can do anything I want
and that's I'm saying this is real
that's [__] up I had to go like oh no
and we got over it was one conversation
I was like you got to do it I'm about it
but there was that hesitation where I'm
like it is but when I go away for three
months it's CU I'm shooting a movie and
I'm like shut the [__] up dude you just
got here you know I'm talking to myself
just got here it is like it is like it
is toxic but you do think it like even
as a woman like I I've definitely had
those moments where I'm like yeah but I
pay for everything right
toxic why are we having this
conversation right what what is there to
talk about I pay for everything right
you know what I mean and so you have to
like and it's hard not to feel that way
because it's hard to make money and pay
for stuff right you know what I mean but
that goes back to the thing I was just
saying but it is like it's it's a trick
one it's a tricky one yeah but you
secretly love it though see that's the
thing so I love it I love even being
stressed about it I love complaining
about it and then I love going like but
I make all I make the money or I make
the majority of the money and uh so I
get to do whatever I want I was like Dad
like that's what Dad said yeah that's
that and it was his house you know what
I call men King babies so sensitive like
we're like little toddlers with with
crowns and we have robes and scepter and
[__] but if you make us feel
insignificant or unappreciated my God
and I'm sure you're the same way yeah
that's the biggest thing I was talking
to um Andrew schz on his podast we've
talked about this a little bit but it's
like that is the biggest thing that I
don't think men communicate well and
like I don't think women acknowledge
well it's like just being appreciated
and acknowledged for the level
of stress M I am taking off away from
your life right right right like there
is a level of stress I've eliminated
from my fiance's life right you know
what I'm saying all you need she doesn't
know she's never seen the light build
she's never she's never seen the gas she
doesn't know what things cost you know
in the house right that is like a level
of adulthood that I'm just like you
don't have to worry about that I will
worry about that for both of us the
acknowledgement of like hey thanks for
that that right it it seems it matters
so much and I think and that's the King
baby thing yeah and I think but I don't
know that it's King baby it's like I I
need something to keep going I guess
what it is is though it when you're
taking care of all of that and you want
to look like a warrior with a sword on
your shoulder it's can be a little
confusing that you're also like but I
also just need you to go like hey Sam
thanks for uh yeah but I'm I'm a [__]
person I you know like no I want to be
be very clear Val Nails it when I go on
the road she goes thanks for working
hard for the family I never told her to
say that that's but that's all you need
that's all I need that's what I'm saying
she even says she'll use the Lang this
is a good Rel this is a good person
right here she'll use the language of my
pain like when I go on the road it's not
a
vacation back to me she'll go I know
it's not a vacation I know you're
working hard I'm like so I'm I'm being
seen like not so Val's a I call her a
love genius she figures out how to loves
somebody and she loves them perfectly
that's good but like when I see
relationships that are decaying I'm just
like and and I'll give it back to Val
when I come back I'm like when I'm alone
with my daughter for four days by the
end of it I'm losing my mind I'm
literally like for real not making and
that's good choices like and that's the
key right haven't bathed the key that's
the key that's the key you have to you
have to reflect it back to the person
absolutely like am I fiance like
we're we're at that place now it took
some work but she definitely now would
be like thank you for like you know work
is off for us thank you for the Lifey
Prof and I know like thank you thank you
just in like y I see you you know what
I'm saying but I also had to learn to be
like thank you for making a home for me
because this helps me and balances me
and like this it also allows me to go
out here and do what I'm doing because I
know I have this stable thing here and
if you're not here building that then I
don't have that and I appreciate that's
not nothing just CU culture doesn't pay
for it doesn't it's not valuable
emotional space physical space all of
that stuff everyone's going to laugh I'm
always bringing up the show alone have
you seen the show alone no it doesn't
matter I hadn't either somebody just
turned me on to it they just drop people
off in the woods and they are alone as
long as they can be and they get to
bring 10 items I like that dude it is a
feminine uh feminist master class
because there's men it's the most male
female show I've ever seen in my life
you will like it it's on Hulu okay
there's like nine seasons of it you you
and your fiance are going to love it but
the men are so Men first of all they
never admit when they fail that's my
number one if they if they tap out it's
always because the contest is stupid
it's not because they couldn't do it
they're like I just decided this was
Dumb and it's like cuz you failed cuz
you were scared of the bear and the
women you're like worried about these
women cuz they're like knitting like a
tapestry for the wall and you're like
lady go out and forage or a good hunt
and they're the ones that make it so
much longer than anybody and they're
fine they're like whistling and sitting
in a chair they made it's kind of like
naked and afraid you watch naked and
afraid it's exactly like Naked and
Afraid except they have that's how the
women are naked and afraid if you notice
like the guys will always be like I'm a
fire master I'm no fire I'm [__]
going to kill this [__] and then like
the woman will be doing something like
she's taking the like reads and she's
making like shoes and he like what the
[__] I don't need shoes and idiot cuts
his foot wide open he's just like
bleeding out his foot need Sho she's
like you should have just took the shoes
and when a man gets stressed a typical
man gets stressed all of that let's say
all that feminine goodness is on the
outside he gets stressed he forgets all
of it it goes away and it's just what do
you do all day when do you bring in
money what are you good for and you
don't realize like there was a dude on a
loan that was like he was like I don't
move CU I don't have calories so I've
I've labeled out every movement I walk
over here and I get water and I walk
back that's 10 calories the most
masculine thing I've ever seen that dude
tapped the [__] out cut to a lady like
chasing a squirrel she's like this is my
god I've named him like she's going to
thrive meaning making purpose making
Community Building even a relationship
with a place that's when I say Feminine
men are obviously capable of it but that
is so undervalued yes yes yes in your
life I I know you already know this my
life I'll keep it to me would suck I say
this to Val all the time we live outside
of the city I'm like walking around in
beautiful nature I'm like I never would
have made it here I would have been a
dumb ass [__] successful comedian
living in like a cop's apartment no
seriously no seriously it's like I come
home and it like it like smells good and
there's like pillows on the couch and
it's like welcoming me and it's like
clean and there's like love in there and
that's it it's not the cleanliness it's
the love and I'm like oh yeah this is
why I'm out doing this thing I don't
know if I didn't have that and I was at
the level that I'm at right
now I would be like it would be sad yeah
of course it would be sad and you see it
I don't I mean to judge people but I
know some people that don't share their
life dark and you see it and they I was
just talking to my friend about this
like cuz he you know he's was kind of
going through with his girl and I'm like
but yo like you love her like just dive
in and fix that because like I'm like yo
I be seeing my homies out here 40
something bro nobody bro they they lost
you see it in their eyes they just out
here drifting right they already have
enough money for every new Xbox and the
new TV and all the by the way there are
some people that can do it I'm sure but
I see a lot more gols and vampires you
know it reminds me Bill bur I was mad at
my manager I love you Dave reth uh I
really do and but I was mad at him for
something this is a long time ago Isn't
it nice I can't even remember why I was
mad and I asked Bill Burr about it
because I was like you ever think about
like not having a manager and he was
like dude no what are you going to get
to the top and have no one to share with
yeah he saw that it's not it's really
not a head relationship it's a heart
relationship even a work relationship
like that you're like no it's actually
about sticking through oh my God like
I've had the same manager since I
started you know and that doesn't make
sense always right no but it worked
right it worked it worked and you know
it shoes on naked and afraid it worked
and we like uh the special you know just
came out so she was in New York um and
we just were sitting at the bar and we
were like God damn man look how far
we've come right look where we started
this relationship look look what I was
doing look what you were doing cuz
they're not just a person memory yeah we
got we got a shot we like cheers we got
a little terot and we were like man yeah
we're [__] here you know like yeah
man you need that [__] you need that
[__] at least I need that [__] because
in that story it's not just another
person we're not just talking about
codependence like it would be sad at a
bar alone no that per your manager in
that story is actually the record of
your life you can't even hold it all
together no Val will go this is Val
she'll go P you get sad every year
around Christmas and I'm like I do yeah
like you know what I mean like I don't
even know myself it takes two people to
know a person for sure no absolutely I
think for anybody with an ounce of depth
and and and and allowing themselves to
live you know you need I need some cloud
storage oh yeah man my fi hard drive the
same thing like I'll be like I forget I
always forget the day my mom passed but
I'll be in a funk September 29th I'm in
a funk I'll always on that day I'll
never go oh that's what happened today
but I'll just be like I'm in a [__]
mood right and my girl just like it's
the 29th and I like oh I like I don't
know what's going on I'm just like
[__] Moody that's what I mean we
don't even know what we need we need
help we need help isn't it wild we need
help if you if you had a baby your baby
the way that like trauma carries over
genetically your baby might be in a funk
on isn't that why yeah isn't that crazy
absolutely I I was just reading a book I
forget what it's called but I was
reading a book about how like they're
finding out more about scientifically
it's not like crystals and [__] they're
like no people are seeing like trauma
you better not say crystals ain't
science to my girl crystals are science
guess how much I paid for this Crystal
she'll smack you up I always think
you're about to sign a huge deal I said
that to her though and she got pissed
off I was like cuz she's like into
Crystal she's an empath whatever
and I will say she is an empath I did
not believe in that but I've grown to
understand you mean she has like
intuition
meaning
she feels what other people feel deeply
wow in a way that I had to say this is
something going on because I do not yeah
you know what I mean I don't like I
absolutely don't and she like and I'll
tell you the moment that I was like no
cuz she's always said it and I've kind
of like okay you know what I mean you're
an empath shut up and you know she'll
like it will be watch she cries every
movie even if it's like a kid's movie
She's you know she's like wet face like
oh my gosh and I'm like that's so dumb
but I didn't put that into like your
like just just just just idiotic but we
were at the
airport and there was a kid he was going
off to war you know like you know when
they be like at the little and his mom
was there cuz you know when they're
going they like their parents come all
the way up to the gate or whatever so
his mom's at the gate and he's hugging
his mom and she's squeezing him so tight
and she's crying and he's crying and
she's wiping his face and he gets on the
plane and we're all just get in line
everybody's just like yeah that's their
situation I turn and my girl is balling
like balling and we get to the seats and
she's just like I feel so bad for this
mother and d d and I'm looking at the
whole the rest of the plane could care
less yeah yeah you know what I mean like
I'm Premier 1K and yeah everybody's just
doing their business to be on the plane
and in that moment I was like okay yeah
it's a different thing it's a different
thing yeah I'm glad you figured that out
though you balanced your I don't want to
minimize you I'm a head too I'm a top
down Val's bottom up it sounds like you
found a bottom up yeah and that's good
yeah if you had two heads no and it's St
me to like now like I'm really sensitive
to that for her like like if I'm
watching something that's violent or
something I'll be like hey babe is are
you okay or you know like because I'm
like B really does [__] with her yeah
and if you're like me you've been
together like 17 years yeah off college
so it's probably already happened or you
tell me if it's already happened I'm now
more in touch with how uh tender I can
be like i' Val calls it my protector I
get mad and I get strong and she's like
is there like anger is sadness and
disguise that sort of thing and living
with somebody who like you're I want to
say girl I want to talk cool I want to
talk cool Sam but your your
partner it starts to rub off on you and
you start to see like oh they're safe
and you start to realize like it's safe
for your your vulnerability to start
coming out that's what I like about
people like those yeah yeah for real and
she's very
um she takes care of feelings very well
like once you like allow her to see them
you know that's great a safe place for
you and then you can have your feelings
yeah yeah it's great and what oh we love
our ladies We Love Our Ladies
That's So Dope why marriage after 17
years why marriage I mean I'm into it
well it's like off and on first of all
so it was like we were consistently
daing for 17 years you know it's off and
on we' be daing then we'd break up and
we'd still be friends but we're [__]
other people then we might see each
other somewhere and [__] and then be
like maybe let's be you together again
and then go our separate ways you know
for a lot of the time we were living in
two different states and you know stuff
like that so it's only been like we are
living together consistently like for
the last six years it's like old new
yeah yeah yeah so it's like old new in
that way and um for me i' I've thought
about this cuz I've also been married
before and divorced um me too I thought
about this and uh to me it is it's not
like oh marriage is going to make me
love her more or change anything I do
think marriage for me is about standing
up with your
community of you know your family your
community yeah
and saying like this is the person I
want to do this with and hold me
accountable that's it yeah you're
folding them in yeah I I don't want to
I'm not grading your answer but I
[__] love that because it's not about
our wedding wasn't even about me and Val
Val and I already knew we loved each
other but we were like and and if you
want one piece of you didn't ask for it
but like the wedding is like what does
your love look like and you let people
visit it
it's [__] emotion your going to be
cry so hard but it's like and then you
say look at this look at how beautiful
it is and it's even in some vows it's
like and when things get if they get
weird or strange or I come to you help
me remember this help me remember this
hold me accountable and hold me
accountable to the words that I'm saying
to this person hold us accountable to to
this thing that we're dedicating to to
be in with each other that's why not
Vegas you can't call up the
and like what did I say nothing against
that I'm just like that wasn't for me I
guess I am saying something against that
I'm so scared of offending somebody
sorry Vegas people I'm just saying like
and you watch the married people this is
how I know I'm I feel like I'm right
married people every married couple that
comes to a wedding their vows are sort
of like renewed and like relit by that
experience cuz you're remembering the
whole thing although to be fair I think
there were like four married couples and
I think I think they're all
divor I know it's what it is you got to
go no okay I mean we did we did it we're
doing a good chat here yeah I have
nothing I don't I I hate it here La yeah
I have nothing to
do so no trust me I'm I'm being I'm
being very
entertained I'm with you I I kind of
love that you don't love La it would be
weird if like I thrive here I hate this
place what what what what's the
headlining hate about it [__] sucks
like it the headliner that it sucks it
sucks so bad just one okay I have so
many I wish you had like a bear or a
drink you know I Fu my we might have a
I'm fueled by alcohol beer in there if
there's a beer in there I would love it
I'm also like hung over oh no you don't
seem hung over at all cuz I do this baby
I told you I told you I went through
some troubles yeah that's right your
troubles I thought there was oh [__] is
that a beer or kambucha
n that's a beer and it it looks like a
Michelob which I've always thought to be
a black brand so here we are yeah I've
always thought black did foreign like
German there you go there you go oh my
God it's a blonde too is it a Twist or a
bang a [__] sexy guess what I can get
it oo you're a man there we go bang so
now I didn't I didn't mean to I know you
love uh man moments I didn't mean to
take that from you no no I'm a comp
woman yeah I was but you know what I
like being taken care of too I also like
being taken care of I like when a man
mans this podcast just took a really
interesting turn I love it so this is
the thing La [__] sucks because when
one there's nothing to do like let's be
like really honest there's nothing to
[__] do other than Show Business
which isn't Show Business and then like
hike and it's like that's not fun
there's not like it's it also sucks
because like there is no there's no like
cool hangs right everything is By
Appointment like if I want to go to
dinner with you I have to call you on a
Monday you'll tell me you're available
next week y around 7 on a Tuesday and
then I'm going to cancel on you too like
that's what we do nobody's coming to
this dinner and it's like who [__]
wants to like live like that like are
you in New York I'm in New York I love
it I can't imagine living anywhere else
also it's just like there's no [__]
culture here like let's be for real
there's no real like museums there's no
art anytime I see a Broadway play that
comes here I'm like I'm not seeing a
[__] in new [__] Los Angeles are
you stupid it's Ben Manuel marindo yeah
I'm like not doing that dumb I feel like
it is a good place if you have like kids
I feel like it's a place people come
when they're done living it's like I
have I have my kid I got I just want a
nice school I want some you know a
better house yeah a better house but
like but it's like kind of over for me
I'm not going to go outside anymore and
I don't it's over for me kind of over
for me and I'm like I'm still out here
I'm in these streets you know I'm up in
New York till 4:00 a.m. I'm like I'm
eating dinner at 10 I'm bar hopping I'm
going to art exhibits I'm hanging out
with musicians I'm going to plays
there's always an Uber or a cab yeah I'm
doing stuff and I'm just like anytime
I'm here I'm like I've done
nothing nothing you can yep I'm not even
defending it you can go to the beach and
walk around I hate the beach you hate
the beach you can eat you can eat good
food I live in New York the food here is
ass it's okay every time I've been
bought someplace in La they like it's so
good yeah I'm like I'm not saying this
cuz you're cuz you're black have you
been to rosos yes it's fine I like that
it's fine it's not that's not that's one
of it's good but it's not like it's not
phenomenal it's not blowing my top you
know it's good food you know but yeah
I'm not the guy
Sushi you like sushi now you're just
yelling out
food Greek food
you this I feel like yeah I like sushi
you should go to Sugarfish yeah yeah who
cares even as I say it I'm like who
cares you said it you know what I said
New York is where you're gambling and La
is where you the sad little quiet place
you take your Chips you you and you cash
them in but that's just a nicer way of
saying what you said which is I'm done
yeah I'm done yeah I'm done I'm still
playing yeah you're still playing so I
ate it here I'm like there's nothing to
do all my friends suck all my friends
who live here they suck now they suck
I'm like hey guys you oh man I got to
like pick my kid up
from oh my kids doing baby yoga and then
after that I got to pick up some bread
you know it's just like even [__] that
they got to do like I got to get pumpkin
bread cuz there's people coming over
tomorrow like
[__] what is this pumpkin bread get
me out of here get me out of here suck
do you feel the isolation of this place
too yes I feel so isolated I'm depressed
here it's truly like it's sad people
just get over it there's no fix for it
it's so sad they just get over it and
it's like New York you can walk out your
door at 1 in the afternoon and not come
home till 4:00 a.m. because the city
itself has just swept you up you know
with no real plan you could be like I'm
going to this thing and then you're like
oh I'm going to stop in here oh then you
bump into somebody on the street and
they're like let's go grab a drink over
here people are like at La you bump into
somebody on the street they always so
busy doing nothing yeah you know you
can't get a person to slow down but
they're not doing [__] you can't you
can't B on the stream like yo let's just
grab a drink real quick like I got to
[__] go do nothing you like what what
are you going to do well they're also
they're driving so they can't get a
drink with you right which is also like
it's [__] [__] it's like you
[__] don't drink and drive it's
just not a real place I can't deal it's
like everything's so like [__] here
it's like you'll be out with somebody
and you'll be like let's do a shot and
they'll be like oh no I drove to it's
like if you can't function your car off
of one
shot what the
[__] what the [__] I mean I can't
disagree with you and the dumb and
everybody's like recovering and nobody
wants to it sucks you know Sam we're
we're saving you a seat when you're lame
and want some pumpkin bre pumpkin bread
not com and do you want to have
kids maybe no no no my fiance thinks she
does but she doesn't but it's just kind
of like a fantasy you that's what I
that's how I feel I know it sounds
[__] up T you set me up sound [__]
up and the problem with Pete what I
realized the issue with Pete is he looks
mad innocent like he doesn't have all
these [__] up dark thoughts and then
he like presents them just like light
that
fantasy and and then you're like
agreeing but you look like the monster
you
know and then we cut me out of the video
it's just you it's like such a [__] up
setup but no I don't this is the thing
she says she does and don't until she I
don't believe her CU she's not doing
anything to do it we're not we're not a
straight couple I can't just nutting her
if we really want to do this you got to
do some stuff she hasn't done the stuff
so I'm like if she starts doing this
stuff and she comes to me one day like
yo I got my ex checked it's this it's
that I'll be like oh she wants to do
this and I'll step up like you know and
I will do it cuz like I'm not going to
deny her that but it's it's either way
for me I'm not strongly no I'm not
strongly yes I think you'd be a great
parent I mean that feels well that's
what freaks me out too is that I know if
we have a kid I will be here I will be
cashing in because that's why I'm like
when I see you in line at the pumpkin
bread I know me like I would be I would
take it so so [__] serious because I
had such a great mom and because I lost
my mom young and I she I know the
importance of being parented well right
because of what I went through I would
take it so serious and I feel like I
also would become very maternal I feel
like all like my the femininity in me
would come like spewing out of me and I
would just be like this mushy
mommy mess that's interesting and I
don't want that you know that Patrice
pit don't want it do you know the
Patrice bit where he's like your men are
like fishermen and they catch like a
swordfish and everybody's like wow you
caught a swordfish and then the
swordfish wants you to like stop fishing
and stop he he he's not just talking
about not seeing other people but he
wants the swordfish being the woman yeah
it's not exactly I can't stand by
everything I suppose but like see I'm so
scared but he says like the fish wants
the fisherman to stop doing the thing
that made the fish attracted to it I
never I never even heard that bit
because you know I I avoided you might
have done it on a podcast I avoided a
lot of Patrice when people started being
like you're sound like you're the next
Patrice you sound like Patrice and I was
like I don't like this I don't know I've
only seen a little bit of his stuff at
that point but I was like I don't want
to receive any more of this yeah yeah
yeah I get that so I just
didn't but I had what's [__] up is I I
was doing a bit when I was talking about
the cheating that was so similar to that
where it was like oh really up to that
point yeah where it was like he might
have just said it on it was like um I
was talking about
like the the nature of conquering yes
you know what I mean it's what attracts
you to a person yes and then it's like
now I'm supposed to just turn that
person off right for you right stop
being stop being a pirate basically yeah
for you I'm supposed to just like shut
it all down when it's like
that's what gets me going that's what
gets me out of that's what got them
going and that's what got you going you
know what I mean that's why so when you
were sh [__] on La and I I agreed
with everything you said people get real
addicted to show business out here let
me say it this way oh oh oh wait I
remembered it it was it was tied into I
was saying like you know I'm not going
to cheat anymore whatever but also why
do I have to play into my girls like
delusions like she wants she wants to
believe I said it probably part of why
that this whole things an issue cuz it's
not only just about I heard her feelings
it's also like she wants me to pretend
that she has the best [__] in the world
like I have to pretend that this is the
best [__] I've ever gotten in my life
and I'm like that's not how [__] works
the best [__] I ever got is some [__]
I ain't got
yet that's the nature of like you know
yeah novelty yes and and excitement yes
it's like I was like the best place I
ever got I didn't meet it on the D okay
like that ain't just that's not possible
the best place I ever got is probably on
the highest cliff I don't
know it's got It's somewhere you know
what I mean it's in the bottom of the
ocean I don't know but it ain't just you
just cuz yeah and that's okay that's
love right you're definitely not the
best [__] I ever
got but that's love I'm still with this
[__] cuz I love you and isn't that
romantic and that is
romantic that is romantic
and I and it's like and the problem is
on women it's like why are you putting
so much value on your [__] yes I'm
valuing you beyond your [__] doofy cuz
that I've been over
that I think you just wrote your wedding
vows you you start Sam is ritten her own
vows well let me get something straight
let me get something
straight I was like you know it's like a
cat I was like you ever see a cat kill a
mouse he first kills the mouse he's like
yes and after a while he's like yes it's
dead but he's that's how [__]
feels you want to hear my married sex
Val and I we were watching alone of
course and there was a married couple on
one of the seasons there's two of them
and one of them is a married couple so
they're alone but together and I go do
you think they're having sex uh because
um they're married and they're together
but they also have to like save their
energy I go do you think they're having
sex like as a strategy and she goes how
long has it been 48 days she's like they
Haven that and I was like that's married
sex it's only been 48 days and you just
got to find some sh like like you that's
why you better be excited about them for
other stuff yeah you have to be and then
you got to find like like I was talking
to my homies I was like you got to once
I start stopped cheating and I was like
okay I have to dial in this is where I'm
at just the [__] I got I got to just be
about this then it's like you got find
ways to make it like you got like you
got do you got like you got like bring
that [__] to Paris you got see what it
do somewhere else you got to put it in a
new environment you got to you know what
I'm saying
[__] what it do here yeah how it hit
off in Paris isn't that off
different what's it like in a different
hemisphere basically the toilets go the
other way let's see what happens with
that's
hilarious that is so but I remember I
was in love with my friend in college
and she was like and she I think she
liked me too it was like a Jim Pam sort
of situation and she was like but do you
marry your friend or your lover and I
was like the [__] your friend like that
[__] is over everyone knows that ends
yeah and they did get divorced I'm I'm
happy so yeah but so did I but then like
now I I Val is my lover for sure and
it's the best sex I've ever had and it's
the most attracted that's real I'm not
just saying that she's exactly my type
and that is not it's not in the it is in
the top five but it might be number five
you know what I mean that's all I'm
saying that's what I'm saying like yeah
my my girl is for I wouldn't be married
to her if it wasn't fire you know what
I'm saying yeah it it was memorable it
was fire it stayed and every once in a
while I'm sure it is again it pops out
that pops back D and I always go it's
nice to know that's still in there and
you know what she says to me that that I
think is really uh sexy too she's like
it's nice we started as a sexual
relationship like that was the initial
like me me me and my fiance too right
and we and we were like [__] it was
[__] yeah at first it was all about
[__] and then you're slowly going
like is this my favorite person you know
what I mean now but like it creeps in
every once in a while and we're really
proud of that yeah you got to be this is
nice you got to be and that's the thing
it's like it's like why again like I
love my girl it's [__] awesome but
I'm just saying like the nature of your
brain is like
the most awesomest I just I ain't
touched it yet you know what I mean
novelty that's just how you know but
absolutely and then you just it is nice
like whenever that happens and we
reconnect in that way it's um It's So
Dope because it truly brings you back to
when y'all first were like it brings you
right back to that Val and I used to
meet in San Francisco and we go that was
some San Francisco sex that was like
when we used to meet in the hotel see
that's what's up yeah I'm happy for you
I appreciate I'm happy for you I'm
working on this premise we don't have to
Workshop but I'm just I think it'll make
you laugh I go I love Val so much like I
want to say the crowd I go if your
partner woke up the other gender would
you be gay for them and I'm like if I
woke up a dude I'd be like I'm sticking
with this [__] dude that's what's up
but then the where I really want to go
with it is I'm like cuz I could just use
a break I just I would love to get
[__] for a CH oh my God oh my God I
just I just put out a bit where I'm
talking about how get out my head I
swear to God I just I just put out this
bit where I'm talking about how I don't
want to strap my girl anymore because
it's hard to [__] like a man and I
didn't realize how much work was
involved see you're like our ambassador
you're talking about our stress and the
work and now and now this thank you yeah
and I'm like when I used to get [__]
by men I would I would be like why
doesn't he [__] harder than that he
needs to work harder than that and now
I'm [__] like a band I'm like this is
a lot to do yeah yeah yeah it's a lot
it's a very narrow motion no matter what
you're doing I don't care how Antonio
Banderas you're getting it's still uh
and it's repetitive yeah bro and it's
and it's all on you it's all on you well
that's the bit so dude I go backstage
and I go I'm just losing my mind Matt
McCarthy and I are in The Green Room
this is in Raleigh I had done five shows
and I just go out of nowhere just to
make him laugh I go I I wish I liked
getting [__] I do and I go because it
would because I'm exhausting no it's
exhausting it's exhausting but then I
was like that sounds homophobic to me
but I was like what I really want is
just like I go you don't think a pitcher
at a baseball game ever looks at the
catcher like must be nice yeah just
squatting down there just hanging out
just hanging out swear the balls keep
coming I swear to God like swear you
can't tell my girl she's not doing work
and I'm like baby girl you not doing
[__] A lot of times you making things
harder all these movings and stuff and
I'm just I'm just allowing it so you
feel good but like I really wish you
just kind of like chill
out it's like like a be skin rug yeah
like just be just be yeah that that was
the bit because we were so tired after
five shows I was like imagine all you
had to do is just kind of lay there and
that's what the thing is like this my
girl got and also you got to remember
like I don't feel it so it's just a
workout you feel me oh yeah I'm
not so I'm really just working out and
it's like it became like a fight because
I like come from shows and she's like
you don't [__] me and it's like girl I'm
tired yeah yeah yeah I'm GNA say I got
to do you're GNA lay down I think that's
some that's some nobell peace PR stuff
right there you know what I'm saying
like you want me to to have sex with
somebody with a penis that you don't
have nerve endings in is like the
greatest act of philanthropy I've ever
heard it's it's the greatest act of love
that's what I'm saying you know what I'm
saying and then it's like you're not
even appreciating thato you're literally
nothing three four times I'm just
sweating that's I'm tired that's all I'm
getting out of this that is and then
sometimes you go right to sleep and I
just here with a fake dick that just
looking stupid my [__] looking
dumb there's some comparison embarrass
myself for your goofy ass and then I'm
wearing a harness and also getting like
talked bad about like what
happening what is this you really have
figured out I didn't know that we needed
a lesbian to speak out for men men
issues but we did it's so funny cuz even
after like doing this special and
touring this special like dudes would
stand up sometimes like thank you you
know all that [__] and I'd get off stage
and like women would come to me and be
like I never thought about that I never
considered that this is you know what I
mean and when and cassine Bentley when
he he came to San Francisco
punchline and then he TMS me afterwards
he's like [__] you're doing God's work
he was like he was leaving the show and
there was a couple and he said the wife
went to the husband do you do you feel
that way about the trash and he was like
kind of you you know you never you never
take it out and she was like I'm going
to start to consider that and I'm going
to try to help you with that
wow that I'm not surprised at all I'm
not surprised at all and I think it's
cuz I'm a woman and I I embrace my
femininity as much as I embrace my
masculinity so I think they see me up
there as a woman and they're like she's
struggling yeah yeah yeah yeah and that
ain't right you you're somehow like the
perfect negotiator to be like I get this
side I've been there now I'm here let me
talk to both sides because it's it
because you don't realize how hard it is
till you're really you have to do it and
like simple stuff as simple as a trash
it's was like I was out there one night
I'm [__] struggling okay like one I'm
not I didn't I wasn't raised to do the
trash so this isn't something I've been
doing since like boys you've been doing
this [__] since you're like 10 it's like
get it that's your job you know so you
have a live experience with the trash
how to Wrangle it how to deal with it
when it goes a ride you know what I mean
a tear I'm new yeah y'all on it I'm new
I'm new to the trash business you know
what I'm saying I'm out there it's in
the big thing it's heavy I'm
like it's night time you know I'm
vulnerable it's like it's like 2 a.m.
I'm like yo there's Predators there's
raccoons and stuff like what the [__]
dog like this is crazy see this is you
no help this is you you know what I mean
yes I do and I'm not surprised I think
that's
actually 100% real like getting people
to talk about stuff is the gift of com
and I'm not surprised at all yes th I'm
happy to say takes trash out that's dope
no my my girl started yeah there you go
she grabs it sometimes she she goes
she'll put it in the thing she's never
going to [__] with the bin but I paid I
found a guy I pay a guy I ain't even GNA
lie I found a man he was doing people's
trash across the street I said hey man
really can you do I too he was like yeah
100 something out he gets it out puts it
on the curb break down the boxes wow are
you in the city yeah I'm in Harlem in
Harlem and you have like a brown stone
or something oh wow that's great yeah
I'm I'm blessed but it was rough for a
while it it was rough but I found a guy
so I'm free
now fantastic we usually end by talking
about uh and I'm only I could talk to
you the rest of your day but we I have
another thing uh another boring ass La
thing I gotta do fit's dog oh great tell
him I said what's up the last thing
meaning of just tacking it on at the end
any framework of God religion
spirituality anything like that for you
absolutely absolutely yeah absolutely um
I don't think all those mushrooms it's
not it's not in the framework of like
packaged religion yeah uh I'm spiritual
you know I pray I pray over my food not
cuz I think you know something crazy is
going to happen to my food if I don't
right to take a moment to acknowledge
yeah acknowledge myself acknowledge that
there's bigger things that play and just
to reconnect to humanity as s to think
about others as much as I'm thinking
about me you know just to Center myself
um well gratitude is real magic yeah you
know what I mean like taking that moment
is probably slowing you down a little
bit it probably is helping you digest
helping you you know you don't want to
eat scared beat grateful exact that is a
good PR exactly so yeah man just yeah
absolutely absolutely I've I feel like
I've felt God move through my life I've
I I have been in some Dark Places and
I've I've had some dark thoughts and I
have been very lost and I cannot just
attribute it like I did that no there
was things that that might connection to
spirituality and and allowing that to
enter me save me you know for sure
carried you through yeah so what about
your mom do do you still feel a
connection to her I'm assuming yes yeah
that's why I asked what if you were like
no I'm like I can tell that you do yeah
absolutely yeah and when you when you
think about an afterlife or do you think
this is it is it just this one little
thing that thing I don't know my um my
fiance is very spiritual too and we talk
a lot about this kind of stuff and she's
kind of sold me on reincarnation oh yeah
that's interesting yeah I've kind of I'm
kind of leaning to that makes the most
sense yeah I've heard it explained like
imagine if we're underwater and you're a
little tornado you ever see like a
tornado underwater like in the bathtub
that's like you and you exist right now
but you're really just made of water
you're made of the same thing everything
is and that's true scientifically
speaking you are just a localed
phenomenon called Sam and I'm a local pH
and then like when that tornado goes
away that's death and then maybe that
same water gets reanimated another thing
you see that sort of recycling happening
you see that sort of repurposing and the
impersonalization of
energy I get it I'm with it yeah and and
kind of the way you just like it starts
without a start right you just hear yep
it ends kind of yep and it's like
what's I I can't imagine then we just
like all hang out somewhere else yeah
you know I'm like what keeps refueling
it and then you do have those moments
where you're
like I've been here before you know like
this is not as unfamiliar as it probably
should feel but it's also not familiar
yep I get that like we're playing a game
with ourselves I feel that I don't even
feel it you know I even sometimes go
like flat earthers and stuff people that
are out there getting weird about stuff
I'm like I think they're picking up on
an overall feeling of this isn't it yeah
and also they're picking up on an
overall feeling of no one knows what the
[__] they're talking about that's right
so it gets I I would say misappropriated
to something like birds aren't real or
whatever it is but it's also that we
need to stop lying right there is this
essence of lying that's underlying this
whole experience and we need to cut it
out so a flat earther is kind of right
because that's what that's what saying
what came out no the Earth isn't round
actually the sh is just like kind of O
BL longy pancakey looking and it's like
well baby you've been lying to us right
these so these [__] aren't
their investigation may have led them to
go it's completely flat and that may not
be true but what you saying wasn't true
either there was something in between
it's like why weren't why aren't Globes
just looking like this old blogy thing
that we are why why isn't that how we're
drawing it why isn't that we're
expressing it in the world so they're
not wrong for their curiosity it's just
I feel like the same thing that that
happened with with Trump and Co it's
like you can't yell at these people and
keep telling them they're [__] dumb
and they're conspiracy theorist and then
we come around later go oh yeah Co
wasn't a lab yeah is that what happened
yes absolutely absolutely like the
government was like this was a leak from
a lab in China we think oh wow wow we
think that is the origin of how this
happened well that what I'm saying is
that that itchy feeling of is this a
dream like Sam have we done this just as
a fun thing did we do this podcast
before exactly yeah you know what I me
deja vu deja vu thing and like and also
last night I had a very rich evening of
dreams and when I wake up it's all gone
but that's what I mean about like the
the stop lying is just overall cuz we
could say like hey we don't know yeah
yeah yeah yeah right we're unsure right
that's what they could have said about
Co we're not quite sure they have to
give an absolute that it's absolutely
not this cuz it's like your parents it's
like it's like parents going like well
because like I don't lie to Leela but I
catch myself being like yeah why can't
you be that close to the TV and in the
80s you just go cuz you'll go blind yeah
and I go baby it's just not what we do
like like think about how we grew up we
grew up thinking that cats and dogs hate
each
other hatte each other that like
literally I remember being a kid being
afraid like oh I got to get this cat
away from this dog before it's devoured
and I see video after video of kittens
laying on dogs licking dogs faces dogs
licking the kitten back they chilling
watching TV and I'm
like why did we spin this tail right
right well you've maintained and what I
think informs your spirituality is we
don't know what's going on we don't know
what the [__] going on and that's the
that's the realest answer anyone could
give you right IE I have a few theories
but I ain't sure right that's my it's in
my special but I uh Barry Taylor said
God is the name of the blanket we put
over the mystery to give it a shape it's
just so we can talk about it it doesn't
mean it's an answer it's a word for the
mystery and we can and what I like about
that definition is we're like it's not
an answer it's not like well you're
going to die and there's going to be
pearly G you don't know nobody know you
don't know you don't know you don't know
nobody has the answers but when you go
like you go into nothing I'm like but we
don't we don't know we don't know we
didn't ask for this we didn't ask for
any of it right
so there's some humility there all right
yeah P you're my boyfriend you're you're
my other girlfriend I got Val now I got
no I love talking with you and and not
to sound like your dad but I'm like I've
watched you just evolve and it's [__]
dope it's really dope and to see you in
your special and to see you now and go
like that's who you were the whole time
yeah now it's like you're totally
comfortable and you understand yourself
and it's great to watch a thank you yeah
would you uh what time is it uh 12:40 oh
we got to go we went an hour 40 [__] a
little longer wait hour no it's almost
two hours because we started like 10
minutes early okay I think we do have
time for this last question then can you
and it doesn't have to be a long answer
but can you think of a time in your life
you laughed so hard you were crying and
you fell over like a really really
really really really hard laugh here are
the you got it go ahead go ahead you
have I was going to say sometimes
someone fell sometimes people farted
sometimes you're in church
I got it so you know Boston yes when we
were kids my cousin used to live in the
south end they had just opened this uh
this housing it was like the first
housing project okay in the south end
kind of um well really know the second
don't don't don't let me get cussed out
by people who live in Matthew and Manor
but it was called 10 city or whatever
and they had moved like low-income
people in and but it was like right in
copi so literally you walked out of the
one side of this structure and you were
like kind of standing right in front of
cop Mall it was like that close so we
would you know wreak havoc over in that
area we were [__] kids it was all the
snooty white people yeah my cousin well
I would go visit all the time and it was
like all the snooty white people lived
over there and so we were just like we
would just run around we would recap we
would do any and everything run by knock
people's hats off their head go to the
mall and throw berries down and hit
people in the head and like dip off just
goofy ass [__] so when they were on
Newberry Street and you know they have
all those outside restaurants yeah and
we bump into my older cousin's
girlfriend we called we called her woman
cuz that's what he would call her I
think her real name was Kia but we would
call her woman and we were like woman
and she was like what's up and we were
like okay we wanted to play this prank
cuz we were like pranksters we would
always go to the joke shop get dollar
snatchers s bombs we were those type of
kids and so we were like oh we're going
to do this funny thing we're GNA and
this is like pre jackass and [__] which
there should have been a camera on us
cuz we were always like let's [__]
fake a seen in the street like we those
type of [__] idiots and so we were
like yo we're going to pretend to rob
you so we were like you walk ahead of us
put your purse you know on your right
side we're going to run by and we're
going to grab it and then you just like
oh my God my Pur freak out and like did
women go for it she's like for sure but
women we're if we're like I'm like 11 my
cousin's got to be like 14 woman's only
like 20 know what she seemed like a
grown up but she was just 20 she's just
20 so woman's like hell yeah let's do it
we're like cool this is going to be
[__] awesome so it's me my cousin and
my homeboy Craig our homeboy Craig she
walks up and you know there all those
outdoor restaurants we like this is
going to create a scene everyone who's
eating is going to be disrupted that's
all we care about we're about to disrupt
whatever this is a show so she goes my
cousin Gerald's the one who's going to
grab a purse so he goes he grabs it he's
running me and Craig are like kind of
behind and she's doing the thing oh my
God my purse he's freaking out some guy
was parking his like Ferrari I can't
handle this he's parking his F old guy
too he had to be like 60 but he's
[__] cut you know like one those old
guys works out and [__] still he's still
getting butt like he has money and he's
still getting butt yeah he's like he's
looking good so he he's got an anchor
yeah yeah he's like I'm together still
he's parking his Ferrari like on the
street side so he hops out he grabs my
cousin lifts him up in the air my
cousin's still moving his legs right but
he's like
up so me and Craig are we're we're
starting to be like oh
[__] this guy throws my cousin up
against a tree and just starts whing on
him
no no he already has him he's [__]
him up he's like beating his ass oh no
so now we're all dying woman's dying
laughing I'm dying laughing Craig's DED
laughing we're like oh [__] wait Craig's
getting his ass no we're just all
laughing my cousin Gerald's getting his
ass oh Gerald's getting his ass to day
I'm like yo you got your ass beat by a
sixy old man he hates when I say got his
ass whooped so we're dying y we're dying
and then the guy like see like he
recognizing what's happening cuz woman's
even laughing and he's like really funny
[__] joke and then he throws the bag
like hits my cousin in the head not him
he's had enough and he's he just like
storms into the
[Laughter]
and then enjoys a tuna tart All Shook Up
he's like oh my
God it still cracks me up yeah that's
where I was afraid it was going but I'm
also delighted that that's where it went
yeah the fooled Samaritan yeah and then
we just got to go home and like lie to
my
aunt he fell off the bike you know was
he like visibly beat up he was he was it
wasn't like big bruises but my man was
yeah oh my God he got worked oh my God
that is a f I'll never forget that
answer thank you Sam you wel this was
great enjoy fits dog radio hell yeah uh
would you say keep it crispy it's how we
end keep it crispy I love it some people
are like what does it mean you're like
nope that was great thank you so much
you made it you made it wi you made it
win oh yeah you made it with you made it
with you made it with oh yeah you made
it with you made it you made it with all
yeah you made it you made it you made it
with
all